oh we're gonna talk about that a little
bit later in the show but welcome
everybody to EA play I'm Andrew Renee
and while you might recognize me from
the gaming community I'm kind of a new
face around here so this year yeah I
wanted to change things up because they
know that I'm both a gamer and a fan so
they invited me to come and host the
show and I think this year is gonna be a
lot of fun you guys I hope you're ready
cuz we're about to kick the
press-conference off but before we do
that EA play is more than just the show
you're about to watch right behind these
doors there is a fan fest outside and it
is huge this year it's a full 3d gaming
festival where thousands of gamers can
come and play games for free now inside
the theater here there are hundreds of
community members from all over the
world who are going to be capturing
streaming and getting their first
impressions of the games that we're
gonna be showing off here today but
before we can get to that we've got some
reveals of course we're gonna kick
things off with a look at battlefield 5
multiplayer now I know Trevor Noah gave
you the first look yeah we can clap it
up last month but we've got some new
stuff to show you today then we're gonna
move on to FIFA 19 and boy do they have
some big news you guys any World Cup
fans you guys excited
then we've got two new indie games to
share and then I'm gonna come back
towards the end of the show with some of
my favorite developers to give you guys
a nice meaty look at anthem and of
course yeah we got the Woo's for anthem
I'm into it you want you wanna do this
with me but what if they find you guys
if I killed you all the secrets at once
right give him give him a break he needs
to just enjoy the show
so that further ado let's get things
started
[Music]
[Music]
right it's time to kick this thing off
it's been two weeks since a real
battlefield
you know what it's been exciting it's
been a lot of speculation and so many
brilliant remixes of a reveal trailer
but there's also been lots and lots of
questions from the community and we've
heard you you want to see more gameplay
innovations you want to know how
customization actually works we want to
know more about our take on the Second
World War so today we'll show you more
gameplay and what this is the deepest
and most immersive battlefield yes it
certainly is you will be able to dive
and smash through Windows to surprise
your enemies where previously defenses
were stationary you will now be able to
move these weapons around on the
battlefield and gain advantages in our
renowned destruction system is back and
more impactful than ever so well you
can't really hide from those pesky tanks
and more as they come chasing you for
you as they rip through those buildings
and you will now be able to customise
your soldiers your vehicles and your
weapons not only for the gameplay but
for the looks as part of our portrayal
of the Second World War that's just the
tip of the iceberg in Belleview 5 you're
going to see a lot more of our new
gameplay systems here at EA play from
our community so let's talk about our
single-player in war stories yes let's
do that so we want to tell you about
those untold stories that got us excited
to start with on this game it's about
what you'll see is really those moments
of human heroism
it is about witnessing the world through
the eyes of the men and women who shaped
the world forever real and real and
relatable people facing the brutality of
war we started off by a exclusive look
at the new least war story over at the
Xbox briefing tomorrow thanks that's
something not to miss tomorrow
so a launching October is just the
beginning you will all go on an
expanding journey through the Second
World War
no loot boxes no premium pass every day
will bring something new and as part of
that journey after launch you'll get
something I know a lot of you have been
asking for mm-hmm
it's Royale
it's through young reimagined for
Battlefield so we bring those pillars of
battlefield with destruction team play
vehicles into this new experience so we
will bring your experience that you
haven't played before in battlefield or
anywhere else but more about that later
this year so with that it's time to show
you what makes pal feel so special
it's the unmatched intensity of our
multiplayer sandbox and this time it's
even more epic fighting across multiple
maps and modes welcome to your next
battlefield experience and this is your
first look at ground operations at this
time even featuring music
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[ __ ] I ain't hot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cuando era Crianza simpson kind of nam
campaign
[Applause]
ab c--'s determing asam even that Vince
here
[Applause]
Desmond is momentum artificers to change
to continue Eric Rita
I stopped working dad the two most
resumed Cueto can p.m.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the UEFA Champions League the
pinnacle of club football were the
world's best clubs compete and icons of
the game like Gerard and Cruyff cemented
their legacies the world's biggest
league joins the world's game and a
special thanks to the legendary Hans
Zimmer and la zone Vince staples for
collaborating with us on the trailer and
I really love the trailer because it
captures our epic vision for how the
Champions League comes to life in FIFA
19 and Lina's gonna tell you a little
bit more about that as Aaron said the
UEFA Champions League is an amazing
addition for the game it's where
football's biggest heroes like Ronaldo
and Neymar
clash every year and it's the place
where champions rise and you've been
asking for this for a long time and we
are thrilled that it's here and that's
why we're bringing the Champions League
across the game will be an authentic
Champions League tournament mode your
club will chase this trophy in career
mode Alex hunter will pursue Champions
League glory in your story mode the
journey and in FIFA Ultimate Team will
be live and authentic Champions League
content and we share more details on
that along with all our other Ultimate
Team features later this summer and all
that's just the beginning
as you know the heart and soul of FIFA
is gameplay and this year we're giving
you the tools to control the pitch in
every moment from your tactical approach
to the match to each technical touch and
we know how passionate you are about
gameplay so we've worked hard to shape
and refine our vision for FIFA 19 with
input from our community from hands-on
tests with beginners to detailed
feedback sessions with FIFA pros and
we're gonna be sharing a lot more about
gameplay throughout the summer but what
I can tell you right now is that the
quality barring gameplay was raised yet
again this year so we look forward to
everybody experiencing the game on the
hands-on sessions this week and also of
course we're extremely excited for
everybody to play it when we launch on
September 28th and that's our FIFA 19
news
headlined by the UEFA Champions League
but I just wanted to take a minute to
pause and reflect standing next to this
trophy is a little bit surreal you know
growing up there's two iconic trophies
that every young player dreams of
winning and for your club it's this one
the pursuit of Champions League glory
but for your country it's this trophy
the World Cup and with the tournament
starting in just five days we're excited
for the world to compete for it in FIFA
18 as you can imagine all of us on the
FIFA team can't wait for the start of
the World Cup and we want to celebrate
with FIFA 18 players which is why we've
just updated the game with a free World
Cup experience on PlayStation 4 Xbox one
ps3 and Nintendo switch but you can take
Ronaldo and Portugal to their first
World Cup victory or you can write your
own story with some great nations who
didn't qualify this year or you can make
a crazy dream a reality for your home
country like mine Iceland who would have
thought that the nation of only 350,000
people would ever qualify and you can
feel their excitement
apologies sandy England fans in the room
I might still sting and Lina isn't only
one who's excited
FIFA 18 players are loving the World Cup
experience so far but we don't want to
stop there we want to invite everyone to
come and join the celebration so I'm
pleased to announce that for a limited
time FIFA 18 complete with the entire
World Cup experience is available for a
free trial on PlayStation 4 and Xbox one
and on PC through origin access yeah you
can download and play the entire game
right now for free yeah
so to kick off the trial we've got some
of the world's biggest creators we're
going to be playing live at the end of
the show representing their Nations in a
little mini World Cup tournament and
this summer will bring so much more for
FIFA fans plenty of FIFA 18 content
centered around the World Cup and we'll
bring you all the details on FIFA 19 but
in the meantime let's all enjoy the
World Cup thank you and I'm Travis Dunn
[Applause]
on the biggest stage
[Applause]
good morning EA SPORTS FIFA 19 you know
the FIFA community never rests 20
million people from 60 countries playing
in competitive leagues this year
well the FIFA team never rests either
bringing the Champions League and the
World Cup and so much other greatness to
fee for this year we can't wait for you
to experience at all we've got so much
to do here today but I want to welcome
you to EA play
it's our third ea play and our second
one in Hollywood and we couldn't be more
excited to have you with us to share all
the games that we have to show you we've
got lots to do but before we get before
we move on I'd like to share just a
couple of things the greys disruption to
the consumption of entertainment media
in the last five years is the
combination of streaming plus
subscription as consumers watching
movies watching TV listening to music
reading books has never been easier and
we believe that disruption is going to
be up have a profound impact on our
industry in the next few years and so
over the last couple of weeks you will
have seen that we announced a new team
from Israel has joined Electronic Arts
to help our investment to extend our
thinking and extend our pioneering into
this cloud gaming world for many people
that's going to mean extending the
experiences they already play in our
partner platforms for others it's going
to mean new games and new modalities of
play across a whole variety of platforms
but for everyone it's gonna mean playing
games anywhere anytime so this week
we've got a tech demo running all of our
games streaming in HD from the cloud to
multiple devices talk about a tryout for
yourselves now it's not quite ready for
a full market primetime yet but it is a
promise of what we hope to bring you in
the future the second part of that of
course is subscription and we started
subscription a number of years ago and
many millions of you have signed up and
experienced the joy of being able to
have full access to a great catalogue of
games today we're announcing origin
access
from en so three things you need to know
about it origin access premier will
bring you all of our new PC games
starting with Madden NFL back on the PC
for the first time in over a decade
then FIFA 19 battlefield 5 and of course
anthem and there'll be many more titles
in the years to come
second you get access to the vault our
library of over a hundred games from EA
and other publishers and third it will
launch later this summer so that's a
little later in the year but if you want
to get started right now and experience
the benefits and joys of subscription
come in and play a free trial of origin
access our by subscription this weekend
thank you and have a great show
[Applause]
[Music]
a chance but I'll get a real tight grip
when I hope that crowd
and all the round things are lost the
more
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody here what's up so I'm here
sitting inside the crowded ei play and I
just happened to find a mr. Vince
Zampella here in the audience Murray's
mine what's going on Vince how you
feeling today I'm feeling great I love
this stuff
I love seeing new games I mean someone's
super excited about that men on PC right
yeah so you guys may have seen that
Vince was tweeting yesterday and there
has been a bunch of speculation so you
want to just get right to it
sure I mean we're not ready to show all
of our stuff yet we're working on a
bunch of stuff it's amazing the teams
are kicking ass but we wanted to bring a
little tidbit so we've been working with
Lucas on getting the name and kind of
the setting for what our Star Wars games
gonna be em we're gonna talk about it
right now
oh you guys got any guesses I bet you
the the Internet is going wild right now
I hope so so the Star Wars name is Jedi
fallen order whoo so Star Wars Jedi
fallen order yeah so it kind of gives
you some idea that you'll be playing a
Jedi
so does that mean I get to like hold a
lightsaber yes so Vince you got it you
got anything else well it takes place
during the dark times trying to be a
little vague here but when the Jedi's
are being hunted so it's gonna be expect
Acula so for all the like the hardcore
nerds out there who want to know like
where in the timeline like what between
which episodes is it between three and
four okay
all right between three four but sounds
like a nice time you got it any other
tidbits it's not a nice it's a dark time
it's a dark time
bad time does that mean this could've
just be all dark and it's serious it's
amazing all right so I think people are
now anxiously want to know like what
wedding can we play the game it will be
holiday of next year 2019 not this year
so sorry to - any hope yeah
but now that we know we can set
expectations we're all can have you
amped up and hopefully we'll hear from
more from you maybe and maybe next year
oh yeah well Vince it was great to see
you thanks for stopping by the show
today we do have a little bit more news
on Star Wars so I'm gonna toss it over
to Dennis
[Applause]
hello there my name is Dennis I work at
dice in Stockholm on Star Wars
Battlefront 2 I'm really happy and
excited to be here today so thank you so
much for hanging out with me for a
little bit so we launched our games in
November of last year and clearly we
didn't get it quite right so instead of
coming out of the gate sprinting like we
really wanted to we had to take a step
back and make sure that we were
delivering the game that our players
really wanted so we decided to
completely overhaul our progression
system and add a bunch of new character
cosmetics for players to collect instead
so from there we added a new hunt mode
inspired by the original battlefront
games that I loved personally starting
with the Ewoks on Endor and thank you we
it turned out to be by far the most
popular update of the game and the team
loved building Ewok hunt so as you might
know we're currently in our Han Solo
season with content from the movie
coming next week it's headlined by the
new planet Kessel a really dangerous
place and it features the return of one
of our favorite modes extraction so
looking forward a little bit this summer
we will be introducing a new squad
system to the game which will allow you
to team up much easier and play with
your friends we're also adding a new
star fighter mode focused around
dogfighting with your hero ships and
looking ahead a little bit more we will
also be delivering a new large-scale
multiplayer sandbox experience to
focused around capturing command posts
and attacking and taking out capital
ships but that's not all we know that
you have been asking for new heroes
villains and planets from a certain era
that features a very iconic Star Wars
conflict so I'm excited to confirm that
battlefront 2 this year we'll be going
deep into the Clone Wars
it's only fitting that we begin on the
planet Geonosis featuring multiple
levels including the largest level we
have ever built for battlefront so let's
talk about the heroes and villains first
let me introduce the most powerful droid
the leader of the most powerful droid
army in the galaxy general grievous and
yes he will be going up against my own
personal favorites Jedi Master obi-wan
Kenobi finally making its debut in
Battlefront after all these years so but
we're not done that's not it they will
not come alone joining them is the Dark
Lord and leader of the separatist
alliance Count Dooku as well as someone
to bring balance to the force
Obi Wan's unruly padawan Anakin
Skywalker the team at home is extremely
excited to be building all of these cool
things EA and dice are committed to
battlefront we had a rough start but I
really think that this game has a bright
future thank you very much for playing
the game providing us with your feedback
talking to us together we will make this
as the greatest game that we can
possibly build there would be no
battlefront without you so thank you may
the force be with you and enjoy the rest
of a3 thanks
[Music]
hi it's it's really good to see you in
unravel
we used yarn to symbolize love and the
bonds between people in our new game we
we tear that bond of right at the start
you lose everything including your spark
but when things are at their darkest you
find hope and you form a new bond and
your spark is rekindled and it leads you
off on an adventure so welcome to
unravel to
it's a game about fresh starts and
second chances these two little souls
who refused to give up and who build
something new and beautiful together and
the whole game is inspired by that
spirit of optimism and togetherness you
see it's all made to be played with two
characters you can play it alone or you
can play it in co-op with a friend but
there's always two characters they're
sharing one yarn and working together to
get through this adventure this game
it's quite different from the first it's
it's both friendlier and more
challenging but above all it's a lot
more playful and we think it's a worthy
successor and I want to show it to you
now so I brought some help so please not
welcome Michael to the stage so I
producer out cold wood and we're gonna
try to show you a little bit of what I'm
talking about about how you can play the
game and co-op with yourself essentially
so this wasn't prepared so when you're
playing it by yourself you can
essentially pick up the other character
and carry them along through the more
fast-paced segments of the games and we
actually try to include a bit more of
those because we figured that since it's
a co-op game we wanted to have more like
thrill and danger and kind of wild
moments places that were like fun and
exciting
and then when you get to the more
hustler area it's like this when you're
problem solving
you can split apart into two and switch
back and forth between the two
characters because that's how we've
essentially designed all the problems
and puzzles of the game that you're
always working together and helping each
other out and utilizing this bond
between you to overcome any obstacle
that you come across
[Music]
so I guess I'll jump in at this
community so I'm gonna be the direct red
one okay the blue one I'll be blue a
little celebratory flip
[Music]
and the bird is back
[Music]
playing it playing it safe right now
I'll swing alright
[Music]
and I'll catch you
[Music]
nice wing up okay you go
[Music]
okay this is the scary parts it's a
freaking
got it
[Music]
buster
okay I'll go up and distract the grouse
you can I'll sneak up here
[Music]
okay your turn yeah look at me hey keep
it moment for less now go
all right
[Music]
now we can breathe again finally our
company
so that's a that's a quick little look
at unravel to
yeah I really hope you like it and
before I go I just want to send some
some love to the team back home because
working on this game has been and a
completely amazing team effort in so
many levels and everybody has worked so
hard so there's there's a bunch of us
from cold wood here and thank you to
those and thank you to everybody back
home and thank you love you
[Applause]
[Music]
so granduncle
Oh
[Music]
the city waves are mine
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Martin and the brilliant team
had called what the grade the game is
really strong these guys have done an
amazing job and it's clear that they
have a lot of passion and I can't
personally wait to play on rebel to with
my kids but what's even more amazing is
that we will make unravel to available
to everyone today yep you heard that
right you'll be able to take these to
your knees on their next big adventure
starting today the game is finished it's
out so Thank You Martin and thank you
the team at Tobruk back in 2015 we
started in this journey with the
original unravel to seek out the most
creative independent developers and
bring them into our EA originals program
it's been our way of helping these
traders bring their unique games to the
world and to tell their stories and last
year if you remember Joseph Faris was up
here on stage representing his team at
Hays lights and a way out and I think we
all kind of remember that and you might
even remember him from the game Awards
as well I think I did anyhow in March
that game caught fire it's it was in it
its innovative it's fun and it's
something fresh and new and you all
loved it we saw over 2 million players
in the first two weeks and a way out is
such a huge success that Joseph and his
team are expanding and moving into a new
studio so stories like this drive our
industry and it's why we will continue
to work with independent developers to
help them realize their dreams which
leads us to our next year originals
title from a little game studio in
Berlin called Joe my games when I met
this team and I saw the game I was
instantly drawn to a personal this story
was it's one that tower carries a very
powerful and important message and it's
unlike anything we have ever done so
please welcome Connie capper to the
stage from Joe my games to tell you more
about sea of solitude
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Patrick
I still remember during the pitch how
enthusiastic Patrick worth and that
afterwards like our whole team including
me we're super excited it actually feels
a little bit the same right now I am
pretty excited
maybe a little too excited thank you
we are you my small indie game studio
from Berlin and we are developing sea of
solitude or SOS as we call it the whole
journey from the very first concept to
actually becoming a part of EI originals
is simply amazing let me tell you more
about our game when humans get too
lonely they turn into monsters this is
at the core of everything you would see
here and hopefully feel while playing
SOS what makes this underlying concept
so important and so unique asset nearly
every human being can at least somehow
relate to all remember the feeling of
being lonely in my case I started
writing the story when I felt solonius
in my life I think as an artist you
protect your emotional world by letting
it out and putting it into your art I'm
still amazed how like the concept seems
to just flowed out of me like right into
the hand and onto the paper I think this
is also why so many people can instantly
connect this again because it's not a
made-up story
even though
takes place in a fantastic setting in
SOS we try to show how people experience
different kinds of loneliness but also
how Outsiders friends and family see
those who struggle we achieve others and
playful ways so that players who wants
to simply enjoy a fantastic experience
can do so but player who wants to look a
bit deeper can reveal a whole emotional
world beneath it or see of solitude is
about a young woman named Kay who is
suffering from such strong loneliness at
her inner feeling the darkness the anger
the hopelessness worthlessness turns to
the outside and she becomes a monster
the game is about finding out why is
this happened to her but also how to
turn her back into a human or team a
tree the goal is to bring all those
emotions into balance some needs to
become bigger some would be better off a
little smaller but to embrace even your
destructive part or your self-doubt in
the same way you embrace your joy or
your hope this is what being human is
all about and that's what our game is
all about thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
this world that I live in is empty and
cold
the loneliness cuts me in touch with my
soul and no child of destiny
and no fortune son I've just chased you
so long now and to me to run and the day
is here nothing is no alone in my room
[Applause]
yeah I'm the one but I'm not the only
one we are the one we can set you down
and we can put you or not crossover
Gavin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and this is ma soir
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name's shake Evelyn aka young kid I'm
from Seattle Washington the only goal of
mine is really to win and claim a major
it's a big night for young kids he's
been stuck at the quarterfinals and here
he is now in his first championship game
looking to accomplish of goal
34 throws at love t1 that was a
phenomenal
and trainees got the lead 42:19 I ain't
using way more than I love women we have
a credible match up it's a rematch
[Music]
[Applause]
it's gonna be your champion company you
get you wanna get smack together
[Music]
my champion he's fine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay how you doing I've been good you
saw a cover from that butt whuppin Wow
already started hey hi everybody I'm
juju Smith Shuster from the Pittsburgh
Steelers as you guys can see king of
touchdown celebrations
that's pretty far I like that a lot as
you guys know this is young kid madding
18 Madden champion like give it up young
kid how has it been you know your
success in your path you know to where
you're at today it's I've always been a
competitor when I was in high school I
was playing baseball I hurt my arm so
then I picked up mad and then at first I
was really bad I was getting blown out
online but I kept at it I put more and
more time into it eventually I made my
first tournament but I had a big
decision that was the same time as my
graduation Wow okay so the key to be the
number one player in madness to hurt
your arm in baseball number one number
two you said you had the decision to be
to go to your graduation or go to a
tournament so like what did you do
now chase that money I still got my
diploma but I chase that money there you
go we all here chasing money that's
awesome okay now the past two you know
the past few years how has it been for
you I know you had some ups and downs
it's been tough I've had a lot of
devastating losses I've been so close so
many times I made the final on TV and
got blown out of all those losses and
made me gain a lot of mental toughness
and that's how I got this belt that's
awesome that belt is so amazing there's
a lot of you know bling on that belt for
you well today EA play you know first
look at the matting lighting trailer
super excited it's gonna be so fun it's
lit I honestly wish I can stay right
here and talk to you guys forever well
I'm not gonna board you guys we're gonna
go out I'm gonna try to take this belt
you know round two so we're out help you
do
[Applause]
you've worked your whole life to get to
moments like these to the very top of
the mountain battle to the pain and
failure oh just to get to this place
where you've been told legends are born
[Applause]
your form so you can rise and you rise
so that you can truly see see that it
was really never about reaching the end
of the road at all but about all the
moments that got you here
[Applause]
[Music]
you need their position the truth at the
moment to find you or will you define
the moment
[Applause]
[Music]
hello ladies John I'm Nathaniel
perfectional shoutcaster here alongside
redwood studios general manager Michael
Martinez how're you doing today I'm
super excited to be here yeah we're
gonna do this presentation a little bit
differently and give you your first look
at a brand new mobile game in a live
winner-take-all head-to-head match
Michael let us tell us the rules sure
thing
the objective is straightforward destroy
the opponent's base to win unit control
super simple just tap it tap to
destination unit automatically moves
they're the most efficient way to
destroy the opponent's base is with this
giant nuclear missile in the center of
the map control the missile by standing
on a majority of the control points a
bar fills up while the missile is
possessed whoever controls the missile
when the bar fills up will fire the
missile takes two missiles to destroy
the enemy's base and win that's it
sounds right Michael well enough talking
about it let's let's get to this match
absolutely all right ladies and
gentlemen we have an awesome matchup
lined up for you here today fighting for
the blue side of the room if you could
please give a cheer for one of the most
formidable RTS players there is make
some noise for in control
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
his opponents fighting for the red side
of the room a competitive mobile gaming
phenomenon please join me in welcoming
to the stage Nick at Nite
[Applause]
now Mike it's gonna be a real clash of
these gaming sounds the competitive
backgrounds that these players have it
should be a great lunch it really is I
can't wait all right are the players
ready let's get this thing going
ready to go I'm ready to go let's do it
all right let's kick this off a nice
little strategy game yes you out there
it's a good John rrah I'm very excited
for this the players are loading in and
we are ready to the match here we go ah
as the players bases have been deployed
and the action begins like any strategy
game economy will be the focus we drive
harvester to start things off nothing
too crazy I think you're crazy
now the infantry is gonna come out to
hold that top point both players of
course trying to take that position Nick
ignite being able to reach it a little
bit first
in a strategy game that flank position
that in control is going from the top
side also very important as Nick at
nights forces have to circle around the
center right let's see if he's able to
create a two-on-one is he able to get
there he's getting there here comes GDI
with with rhino it's gonna rip up those
infantry yeah going for the
anti-infantry and like any strategy game
the units that you're going to use when
you deploy them will have a huge impact
your micromanagement of your forces and
protecting that economy is helping pick
a night with some attack bikes in the
top here he is in control placing the
turret on the top right side to help
cover that Rhino has attacked bikes move
towards the northwest addition you can
see that the missile is beginning to
ready and firing that that takes out
half your base the most important
objective on the map is to hold those
control zones right and then control
making a lot of progress to that far
right sides of the match it's done a
great job of pulling that down with the
turret and now he's redeploying his
vehicle to the south side bringing out
more infantry to deal with the attack
bikes and as the economy ramps up of
course we've seen bigger and more
powerful units to come out we have there
the drill pod coming in the left side to
hell with it put it with some high
powers right absolutely again it was
gonna tear through those infantry yeah
and he control brings out his first tank
it's gonna be used to trying to help
push back these smaller forces as he
makes his way to the Southside that
missile passing halfway now to control
of Nick at night he will have the
missiles we see it starts to point
towards in control space let's see if in
control can get around to that top
corner able to halt that missile he does
contestant missile put into yellow
position now very important of course
blocking the the passing of those units
is another big factor for the strategy
holding those locations is so crucial as
in control begins to secure the
northwest spot another tanks gonna come
out from Nick it nice to take it out but
now he's bringing up the pitbull as well
to help lock down that North this
missile is very very close to firing
let's see what's gonna happen with
another turret he control blinks he
takes the top that missile and then Wow
and Nick and Knight one shot away from
being knocked out here as the next one
will start sit ready up it's just a
moment's time it controls very heavy
artillery forces doing a great job at
taking control of the map CC as moored
Nick and knights forces move up towards
that north position those harvesters of
course very fiducial very important to
protect those as your economy allows you
to get these big late-game units the
units are gonna come out of it more
slowly as you get more of them on the
field but in control just spreading his
forces out trying to hold this advantage
that he's had so far Nick at night is
trying to get in there but there's a
great turret placement from in control
blocking and just ripping through again
those infantry and we see in control now
moving in tank board there's other drill
powers in with some flame tanks yeah
bring in the flank of course let's play
guys do amazing damage the infantry
helps to clean that out meanwhile two
more tanks coming out from Nick at night
to try and secure those positions it
brings up the laser infantry on the
south side of the hill with that tape
going for counters trying to scout out
and see what your opponent is doing and
make the proper response it's so
important in Stratham salutely Nick a
knife cruising around thinking about
harassing those harvesters coming around
the far side for those rhinos it looks
like he's really pressing it
you see that missile is starting to get
close to flying with us three zones in
control for Nick and Knight looking to
set things back the other way in control
trying to rally his force really doesn't
want to engage with just one or two
units he wants to move all of them
together create a good flank position
and take over that sours in the first
mech units from in control this is the
Wolverine gonna rip down this slope
watch out through this missile and Nick
in there go next missile is gonna end X
missile wedge see what happens we'll
have control of Wolverines as you
pointed out for any control coming out
to trying to deal with these forces but
Nick at nights and a great job getting
mad presence and now also harassing the
economy oh yes yep Wow okay we've got
our first mammoth tank on the board its
Nick big control can get this in
position is gonna do some serious damage
that missile just passed halfway ready
he's also bringing on his first air unit
Wow deal with it a lot going on here
it's got a lot of Rheims that big boy
and in control just need something this
missile is nearly gonna fire it can be
smoothly done where is it gonna go be
able to get it off
[Applause]
amazing what a map thank you so much I
was awesome any thoughts guys I just
came to make mammoth tanks so I've done
my job yeah absolutely
Alec awesome looks a little bit
everything right there perfect yeah
let's hear it for our Nathaniel make a
knight and in control
ladies and gentlemen what you just saw
was the worldwide reveal of command &
Conquer rivals rivals reimagines the
realtime strategy experience for mobile
we're giving players complete continuous
control of their armies in quick
competitive head-to-head matches that
are fueled by skill and strategy now
rivals will be coming to iOS and Android
devices but I'm excited to announce that
Android players can play the pre-alpha
today so head to the Google Play Store
search command & Conquer rivals the
studio has been having an absolute blast
playing this game and we can't wait for
you to play please let us know what you
think thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
command & Conquer for a new generation
now before we close the show with a
spectacular epic anthem I wanted to
share a few final things I am blessed to
be able to work with some of the most
creative people on the planet who come
to work every day to create amazing
entertainment and what I can say about
all of those teams and we can say about
us is that we are always trying to learn
and listen and strive to be better and
so as you look at the 10 experiences
they're going to see today and as you
play games this week there's some things
we hope come through first that at the
very core is choice is that you as
players get to choose how you play what
you play when you play and what devices
you play on that in making those choices
you feel you are treated fairly that no
one is given an unfair advantage or
disadvantage for how they choose to play
that for every moment that you invest we
know that you put so much of your life
into the games we make and that for
every moment you invest you feel like
you are rewarded and you are given value
for that investment and most importantly
that the games are fun that we move past
the grind and that these are experiences
that truly enhance your lives and so as
we think through all the things that
we're trying to do know that we want to
be better and that we want to make great
games and that as much as we love making
games and as much as you love playing
them there's something that is even
greater that we can do together the
power of this community when we come
together to do amazing things is
profound last weekend was the third year
of our play to give program where we
show the world how the power of play can
be a positive force for social impact
millions of you out there participated
in nine in game challenges in our games
loking millions of hours in support of
play to give and to celebrate that we
contributed a total of 1 million
two three charities that share our
vision for a more inclusive world a
world where representation and equality
are not something we strive for
they are the standards and where
bullying and exclusion are not an
everyday threat these three
organizations the United Nations he for
she paces National Bullying Prevention
Center and ditched the label an
anti-bullying organization all are doing
great work and we're proud to support
them through Play to give back and thank
you for your support thousands of us at
EA and millions of you together doing
immeasurable good because we love games
thanks for being with us and thanks for
the incredible privilege of making games
for all of you now without further ado
let's take a look at anthem the guard's
vanished
and left our world and chaos creating
altering destroying the anthem is all
that remains
[Music]
there's just alone coming these walls
can protect us forever
something is out there it wants to
destroy us all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
how cool is that trailer you guys have
seen it a couple of times and it's so
cool every time I see it so I know all
of you like me have had tons of
questions about anthem since last year
because we're all by our fans so we're
gonna do something a little bit
different for the rest of the show and
we're gonna take a deep dive into anthem
so I'm gonna bring up some members of
the bio team to chat with us ladies and
gentlemen please give a warm welcome to
Casey Hudson Marc Dara and Kathleen
roots art all right thanks guys thanks
for coming up today Joe right should be
very exciting so Casey we're gonna go
ahead and just jump right in and get
started with you so now we know that you
all started or case you started your
career at Bioware way back in the day
but you took a couple years off but
before you came back you actually worked
on anthem before you left yeah that's
right so you know first of all it's
amazing to be back it's awesome to be
making games from Bioware fans you know
we have the best fans so it's been super
satisfying to come back to it and you
know I just want to be able to continue
the legacy of the studio and that's kind
of where it started with anthem is just
thinking about you know what is the
evolution of a Bioware game and we
wanted to create a brand new world for
people to discover you know a whole new
world of story and character but we also
wanted to do something that was you know
more of a dynamic and living world in
the game that would change every time
you came back and played it we also
wanted to do something where you know if
you want to invite your friends into it
then you could do that as well so that
was really the initial vision of the
game not an MMO not a multiplayer game
with story sort of bolted on this side
but something new and different and I
think the team has really captured that
vision over the years your fans really
love the stories from Bioware but I
think we're kind of curious how you're
planning to make story work in this
shared world so a great story for
Bioware is really about characters that
you can have a connection with choices
you get to make and feeling like the
stories about you
in a lot of multiplayer games those
things get diluted because you're mixing
multiplayer and storytelling into the
same areas now you can build a solution
to that but you have to really build it
into the core of the game and that's
what we've tried to do with with anthem
so what we call our world my story so
when you're out in the open world the
world is really dangerous and you're
focused on your mission and this is
where other players get to play with you
the thing that's really interesting
about this it's unique for for anthem is
that this is a living shared world so
whether there's weather or it's
nighttime what we're experiencing we're
experienced together everyone that's
playing anthem gonna edit at a moment is
seeing the same thing and this is what
we mean when we talk about our world
it's a shared world that we all
experience together but then when I
finish my mission I come back to a base
like for tarsus and this is a
single-player experience I turn in my my
rewards I talked to some characters I
experienced the choices of my action and
this is where your story really lives
and breeze and by doing it this way we
were able to combine that impact an
agency of a single player story with the
fun of teaming up with your friends to
play co-op in combat and we're also
designing it so that we can add story
for years to come so one of the first
things that we hear when from our
community is they want to continue to
play in our worlds when they finished
Mass Effect or Dragon Age players want
more story and so we've designed anthem
in a way that we can actually add more
story for years to come and it could be
anything a new moment with a character
that you've grown to love or event in
the world that deep into the lore or an
entirely new storyline and plot well I'm
certainly not gonna complain about more
story and I'll take anybody house
there's going to either so caffeine I
wanted to ask you from a writing
perspective since you are the lead
writer can you speak to what it's like
to create a new world like anthem from
the beginning well what's really
exciting for us and not just the writers
but all of the devs the designers the
artists is that we're creating something
new and mysterious for players to
discover so at the heart of the premise
of anthem is a world left unfinished by
the gods but the gods left behind their
massive tools and those tools are in
constant conflict with this unknowable
force called the anthem of creation and
the chaos of those things pushing
against each other means that the world
is constantly being reshaped in new and
unpredictable ways yeah violent storms
mutant creatures gigantic monsters it's
a dangerous environment that you need to
wear a suit of power armor a javelin too
to be safe and now something I think a
lot of players out there maybe don't
stop to think about it's just how much
work goes into creating a new
intellectual property or IP as we've
been saying now you know we've seen all
these different creatures and Mark you
mentioned the storms what's the process
of creating a game like from scratch
yeah it's something we've done a few
times at Bioware
you know and really the hardest part is
getting started just kind of getting off
the blank page so what we tried to do is
we think about the new experiences that
we're trying to unlock for players so
like what is the fantasy fulfillment
what are the new things you actually get
to go and do that are different from
what you've played before so that's
where we start and then once we think
about those things you know that's the
power of creating new IP especially for
games is that you actually get to build
a whole fictional universe that's meant
to bring out a certain experience and
then once we do that then we kind of we
still need to build all the rest of the
stuff and what unlocks us creatively is
to think about like principles around
art style tone and even the technology
and the politics of our new world and
then from there we can actually go and
build out every last detail yeah and one
of the unique challenges for anthem is
that it's a world and experience that's
meant to feel alive like it's happening
right now and so the world is always
changing
weather the storms seasons and yeah it's
a really great concept to write for
because what it means is it gives us the
opportunity to drop into the world
almost in real time a dramatic event
that changes the world for everyone and
that could be anything from game play to
lure the needs of all of the moving
parts in the dynamic world sound really
cool the way that they sound like
they're gonna come together but even
though there's obviously a lot going on
it really all comes back to your
character so let's talk about who we're
gonna be playing as and why we're
fighting these crazy piece so you are a
freelancer uniquely skilled to pilot
these EXO jet these javelin exosuits
and you need those suits to survive and
fight in this world because the world
will kill you but on top of that our
ancient rivals the Dominion have they
discovered a way they think to weaponize
the anthem of creation and so we need to
stop them and protect the free people of
tarsus no I call this power armor a
couple different things as is it a suit
is it a javelin like what's the what's
the cannon term here we call them
javelins and there are four and they
each have unique abilities there's the
Ranger and then there's the Colossus the
Interceptor and finally the storm yeah
so each javelin gives you a different
way to play the game but the thing to
remember is like Kathleen said you're
not your suit you are freelance or a
pilot which means you can decide which
suits you want to use based on your mood
based on the mission you want to engage
it or the use or the javelins that your
friends are using so really what this
allows us to do is we've built the suits
to look like they're built from the
materials of the world so they each have
their own unique abilities let's take a
look at the Ranger now the Ranger is a
more generalized suit able to do a lot
of different things but use really
designed for up close
personal combat one-on-one for the most
part the Colossus is heavier more
specialized but able to really in big
weapons that let them doubt estate the
battlefield I'm just gonna say the storm
looks like it's gonna be my favorite I'm
sure you guys are picking your faves
right now - so the javelins look awesome
but we're gonna take a couple questions
right now so Casey tweeted some of you
may have seen asking for people out
there to send us your questions and the
first one is gonna be from out it's
sweet Nicole who asks as a player who is
all about making their character their
own what kind of customization options
will be available in anthem yeah so we
really want players to express himself
both through customizing the way their
their javelin plays through gear and
weapons but also being able to
personalize the way that it looks both
through paint jobs as well as changing
the actual geometry of the suit itself
we want teams to be able to do this as
well and because you're going to be
using a javelin for a long period of
time we really want you to be able to
make it your own
I'm glad you brought that up because
actually a jail Akeno has a question
connected to customization monetization
how when loop box cosmetics yeah so we
are going to have some cosmetics and
vanity items that you'll be able to
purchase but you're always going to know
what you're gonna buy before you spend
any money on it so no loop boxes no
ability to pay for power so that means
no ability to spend money on game play
advantage at all within anthem but even
more important that we want to make sure
that anthem is an immersive experience
that feels like it's complete from the
get-go so that means the main story a
big open world and an ongoing service
that provides new content for a long
period of time new story new new new
experiences for everyone well I'm glad
to hear that I can make my javelin pink
that's really all I want to know I'm
gonna be honest all right Casey we
talked earlier about this being a co-op
experience so can you tell me a little
bit about how the team game plan anthem
is gonna work yeah it really is about
you know the fun of teaming up as as a
team of superheroes and working together
so you want to get a few people together
of different classes so you know I think
here we're gonna see
the colossus you know just hammering
people on the ground in gameplay we can
have a look at that so heavy artillery
being really strong you know in melee
combat and then here you've got the
ranger shooting down from above and then
they're using calm and you know combos
and special abilities and stuff like
that but what I love is you don't just
run around you're swimming and flying as
well so it's interesting because at the
sleep Jones wants to know how will you
balance multiplayer with single-player
storytelling
so anthems really built around trying to
combine the the impact of having your
own personal story with the fun of
playing with other players but we really
want to make sure that that playing with
other people feels like a choice so for
people that want to just experience the
story we you're gonna be able to do that
now going out into an open world like
this by yourself is going to be a little
bit more challenging than than if the
team of four people and we've really
tried to balance the co-op experience to
be fun even for people that don't
normally engage in this kind of thing so
I really hope that everyone at least
gives co-op a try okay that's good to
know if you want a role solo you can but
more difficult well I know you all are
on the edges of your seats how about we
show a little gameplay yeah all right so
I'm Kevin think you're gonna set this up
for us I will
so the your you and your friends have
decided to play a mission called scars
and villainy the scars have put together
an acid based super weapon so you got to
take them out so you start in the
Strider which is like a giant Walker and
it's your forward base of operations you
have a conversation with your crew
Halleck fey and Owen and you'll hear
Owen he's going to talk us through the
mission as we as we experience it here
and yeah then you just get into your
javelins suit and you head out with your
friends all right well thank you so much
Mark Casey
Kathleen for talking to me about anthem
today we're gonna go ahead and roll the
gameplay now enjoy everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
freelancer time to get to work they said
these bastards made some kind of acid
and using it as a weapon
so find where they're making this
garbage and shut it all down
[Music]
[Music]
owen what's the plan here picking up
loads of scars nearby take a look around
the area but sir be careful
[Music]
right checking out the Skycam some more
look at all the wavin so I'm the other
turrets let it move quickly
[Music]
there's a shaker on it wait something
start get it closer look would you see
those radiant pieces of energy there
echoes from the anthem of creation loads
of scars nearby be careful
return them to the relic you've got to
silence it fast
it's got silence disaster overseas do
you think we get a bonus for wait
something's happening
what the hell was that I think that was
whatever laid all the eggs around here
the sound came from below your position
on the plus side this definitely cancel
what hazard pay there's a trainer this
acid gunk leading down follow it we
should find the source
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys yep and that was that was
actually just a short version of the
full demo that we brought here to LA so
if you want to come by the Anthem
theater here at EA play you can check
out the game lodge so I'm sure the
question on everyone's minds when do we
get to play so anthem comes out February
22nd 2019 on Xbox one Playstation 4 and
PC the mark your calendars everybody
fire after tweaks thank you so much
again to keep the entire Bioware team I
know you guys have that awesome theater
outside so I will see you guys there all
right I also want to give a big thank
you to all of the developers who
showcase their games today and everybody
working hard at their Studios back home
around the world let's give them all a
round of applause now some of what you
saw today you guys have to wait to play
but you guys EA has so much available
right now now for those of you keeping
score you can get your free trial of
FIFA 18th World Cup today and Andrew
told us about the free trial of origin
access yarny is back with a buddy in
unravel 2 which is also available today
plus you can take on your friends in
command and conquer rivals starting
today as well now a lot of a little
stuff that's out today's anybody you
ready to go home and download anything
no you're like I just want to go outside
to the fan fest I get it I get it
so I want to let you guys know to keep
your streams going because in just a few
moments the FIFA 18 World Cup live
tournament is going to begin I'm gonna
head outside and check out the games but
I want to thank everybody for coming
down to EA play today and watching the
press conference and have a great
weekend
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]